HTTP is a stateless protocol,
each request is its own TCP connection.
For example,
if you log into your bank's website,
each click on a URL generates
a separate TCP connection.
In order to carry information
across multiple HTTP requests
such as user authentication,
cookies are used.
A cookie is created by the web server
when the user first logs into the site.
It contains not only user identity
information, but also security
information such as access,
expiration time, and if SSL is required.
The user's browser stores the cookie and
includes it in subsequent requests so
that the server knows that
these new requests are related.
For example, they belong to
the same user login session.